TAKE IT EVEN FURTHER.
THANK YOU FOR BEING WITH US.
JOINING US NOW WITH MORE
REACTION, BREAKING NEWS, MUELLER
HAS AGREED TO TESTIFY IN SENATE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN
LINDSEY GRAHAM HERE YESTERDAY,
BY THE WAY, YOU SAID THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE MUST BE ABLE
TO SEE IT ALL.
I AGREE, AND YOU CAN MAKE IT
HAPPEN, BUT IT WAS YOUR KEY
QUESTION TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THAT I HAVE PLAYED OVER AND OVER
AGAIN.
I DON'T HAVE TIME WITH ALL OF
THE NEWS.
BUT I'VE PLAYED IT PROBABLY
BETWEEN RADIO AND TV, 60 TIMES.
AND THE QUESTION WAS CRUCIAL --
DID ROBERT MUELLER HAVE THE
RESOURCES?
DID HE HAVE THE TIME?
THEN YOU SAID, DO YOU CARE ABOUT
POSSIBLY RIGGED INVESTIGATION,
FISA ABUSE?
I WILL LET YOU TAKE IT FROM
THERE.
>> BOTTOM LINE, AFTER ALL OF THE
LOOKING AT ALL THE TIME AND
MONEY YOU SPENT, DID TRUMP
COLLUDE WITH THE RUSSIANS?
NO.
DO YOU STAND BY REPORT?
DID YOU TURN IT OVER TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION AND THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S THAT I DID, AND I'M NT
GENERAL'S THAT I DID, AND I'M NG
GENERAL'S THAT I DID, AND I'M NI
GENERAL'S THAT I DID, AND I'M NT
GENERAL'S THAT I DID, AND I'M NO
REVISIT IT.
SO IT IS CASE CLOSED FOR ME.
THEY CAN DO ANYTHING THEY WANT
TO IN THE HOUSE, AND I THINK IT
WILL BLOW UP IN THEIR FACES.
>> Sean: I THINK -- LET'S GO
BACK TO SOME OF THE OTHER
QUESTIONS PEERED HOW DO YOU
JUSTIFY HIRING HILLARY'S
ATTORNEY, ONLY DEMOCRATS?
ANDREW WEISSMANN?
HE COULDN'T FIND ONE REPUBLICAN?
NOT ONE?
>> IT WILL BLOW UP IN THEIR
FACE.
THIS WILL BLOW UP IN THEIR FACE.
THE CONCLUSION CAN'T CHANGE,
NOBODY COULD BRING THE
OBSTRUCTION CASE BASED ON THESE
FACTS.
THE PRESIDENT GAVE 1.4 MILLION
DOCUMENTS TO MUELLER.
HIS LAWYER TESTIFIED FOR 30
HOURS, HE MADE EVERYBODY
AVAILABLE TO MUELLER THAT
MUELLER WANTED TO TALK TO, AND
HE SUBMITTED -- ANSWERED
QUESTIONS IN WRITING.
SO THIS PRESIDENT DID NOTHING TO
STOP MUELLER FROM FINDING THE
TRUTH.
>> Sean: IF YOU GO BACK, I
MENTIONED TO JAY SEKULOW, THE
NINE AND A HALF MINUTE PRESS
CONFERENCE HE DID, AND BOY, THE
MEDIA WAS SO QUICK, THEY THOUGHT
CONSPIRACY THEORY CAME BACK TO
LIFE.
IT'S SERIOUS AND SIGNIFICANT,
THOUGH.
I WATCHED IT, AND NUMBER ONE, I
KNEW HE HAD SAID THE OPPOSITE,
WAITING FOR PEOPLE TO CATCH UP,
AND NUMBER TWO, WHEN YOU THINK
ABOUT -- I THOUGHT
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR WAS BEING
VERY GRACIOUS TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL, THREW HIM A LIFELINE.
THEY RELEASED A JOINT STATEMENT
BASICALLY SAYING I DIDN'T MEAN
WHAT I SAID FOR NINE AND A HALF
MINUTES.
THAT OUGHT TO BE VERY
TROUBLESOME ROBERT MUELLER.
>> RIGHT.
BUT I HOPE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT,
BECAUSE WHEN MUELLER CAME IN TO
TELL BARR THAT HE COULD DECIDE,
HE COULD MAKE THE DECISION ABOUT
OBSTRUCTION, HE WAS GOING TO
LEAVE IT TO BARR, AND BARR ASKED
HIM POINT BLANK IF IT IS BECAUSE
OF THE DOJ POLICY, YOU DON'T
INDICT A SITTING PRESIDENT?
HE SAID NO, COMPLICATED FACTS
AND COMPLICATED LAW WOULD NOT
ALLOW HIM TO REACH A CONCLUSION.
SO AFTER TWO YEARS, X AMOUNT OF
DOLLARS, FBI AGENTS, IF HE
COULDN'T DECIDE ON OBSTRUCTION
OF JUSTICE, WHY DO YOU THINK
BARR WOULD REACH A DIFFERENT
CONCLUSION, OTHER THAN YOU CAN
PROSECUTE?
>> Sean: OKAY, SO LET ME GO --
I WANT TO ASK YOU SPECIFICALLY,
BECAUSE YOU WERE THE ONE SAYING
IT LAST WEEK.
FIRST OF ALL, I'M VERY HAPPY YOU
PLEDGED THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, ALL
OF THESE ISSUES, STARTING WITH
THE RIGGED INVESTIGATION AND
HILLARY -- AND BY THE WAY, I
DON'T THINK THE SUBPOENAED
EMAILS, CLEAN THE HARD
DRIVE, I WOULD SAY THAT IS
PROBABLY THE BEST CASE OF
OBSTRUCTION OF JUSTICE I'VE EVER
SEEN, BUT IT ONLY MATTERS IF IT
IS DONALD TRUMP.
BUT YOU ARE GOING TO GO BACK TO
THE BEGINNING.
TELL US WHAT ELSE, SPECIFICALLY,
YOU ARE INTERESTED IN THAT YOU
WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF.
>> I WANT TO SEE THE HOROWITZ
REPORT ABOUT, DID THE DOJ AND
FBI DEFRAUD THE FISA COURT?
DID THEY LIE TO THE FISA COURT
TO GET A WARRANT AGAINST
CARTER PAGE?
I WANT TO FIND OUT WHY THEY OPEN
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
INVESTIGATION AGAINST TRUMP, AND
I REALLY DO BELIEVE THE ONLY
REASON CLINTON WASN'T CHARGED
WITH ANYTHING IS BECAUSE IF YOU
WANTED HER TO WIN, HOW DO YOU
CHARGE HER WITH A CRIME IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE CAMPAIGN?
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, THESE ARE
REALLY GOOD QUESTIONS, AND I
THINK THE FISA ABUSE IS THE TIP
OF THE ICEBERG.
BUT THINK ABOUT THIS, WE ALREADY
KNOW WHAT CHRISTOPHER STEELE IS
GOING TO SAY, BECAUSE HE HAS
ALREADY SAID IT.
SO HERE'S THE BIG QUESTION.
IF SO, IN JANUARY OF 2017, THERE
IS JAMES COMEY IN TRUMP TOWER,
SAYING WE HAVE THIS DOSSIER, IT
IS SALACIOUS, BUT IT IS
UNVERIFIED.
JANUARY OF '17, BEFORE HE
BECOMES PRESIDENT.
OCTOBER 2016, HE SIGNS THE FIRST
FISA APPLICATION THAT WE NOW
KNOW, BECAUSE OF STEELE'S
TESTIMONY, I HAVE NO IDEA IF ANY
OF IT IS TRUE, UNDER THREAT OF
PERJURY, THAT MEANS IT'S AN
UNVERIFIABLE DOCUMENT.
AT THE TOP OF A FISA WARRANT,
I'VE BEEN TOLD, I'VE NEVER SEEN
ONE, IT ACTUALLY SAYS
"VERIFIED."
HAVE A QUESTION IS, DOES THAT
SOUND LIKE A PREMEDITATED FRAUD
ON THE FISA COURT JUDGES?
WE KNOW COMEY LIED IN
OCTOBER 2016, JANUARY 2017, BUT
HE HAD TO MY OCTOBER 2016
BECAUSE STEELE UNDERCUTS HIS
STORY.
>> WHAT WE KNOW AS McCABE SAID
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER, THERE WOULD
BE NO WARRANT AGAINST
CARTER PAGE.
HERE IS THE QUESTION TO ASK
ANYBODY: IS THE DOSSIER VERIFIED
TO THIS DAY?
WE NOW KNOW, STEELE SAID I DON'T
KNOW IF IT'S TRUE OR NOT.
COMEY IT TELLS THE PRESIDENT IN
JANUARY OF 2017, SALACIOUS,
UNVERIFIED, IT'S THE SAME
DOCUMENT THEY SAID WAS RELIABLE
AND TRUSTWORTHY IN OCTOBER.
IT DOESN'T ADD UP.
THE DOSSIER IS A BUNCH OF
GARBAGE.
I CAN TELL YOU WITHOUT ANY DOUBT
IT'S A BUNCH OF GARBAGE, AND IT
WAS USED TO GET A WARRANT
AGAINST AN AMERICAN CITIZEN, AND
SOMEBODY IS GOING TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THAT.
>> Sean: ALL RIGHT,
SENATOR GRAHAM, GREAT TO SEE
YOU.
BY THE WAY, TREY GOWDY SAID HE
IS GOING TO TREAT US.
>> I WILL BELIEVE THAT WHEN I
SEE IT.
>> Sean: ONLY COMES ON THE
SHOW WHEN JASON CHAFFETZ IS
HOSTING.
I'M A FAN OF TREY GOWDY, HE'S A
GREAT GUY.
>> I WILL BELIEVE IT WHEN I SEE
IT.
[LAUGHS]
>> Sean: I THINK WE WILL ALL
HAVE TO PAY, BECAUSE IF HANNITY